yes we make mistakes we should learn
from those mistakes I raise them that's
the biggest mistake of all never getting
back on the horse and trying again
dwelling on what you've stopped on is
the quickest way for the next thing not
to work rise and shine it's an espresso
time what's up believe nation it's Evan
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message rewrite your
mistakes over to you Gower Gopal das
[Music]
when you write you will most certainly
end up making mistakes what's truly
great is that right behind you is
attached an eraser and you can actually
correct that mistake
and once again write the right thing
ladies and gentlemen even in our lives
we make so many mistakes and what's
amazing is God has given us the
opportunity the chance to erase them to
correct them and to rewrite our stories
we all make mistakes I remember I once
went for a program and a gentleman came
to me and said Prabhu gee I'm your fan I
said why he said your talks are really
inspiring especially the jokes I said
what about the points man he said the
points are good but the jokes are great
I said to him come on all the jokes are
only meant to really pass on the message
and drive home the point and just as we
were talking a little boy came running
and I said your son right he said yeah
and just following the boy came a lady I
said your daughter right and the man
turned blue and the lady was like all
smiles a year-to-year smile because she
was not as daughter she was actually his
wife the guy turned to his wife and said
Prabhu G koja seriously Neil Innoko one
good joke smart [ __ ] both other day oh
my god I realized God I had made a big
mistake there by asking if it was his
daughter when she was actually his wife
we all make mistakes now anyone who
comes to me with people around
I never asked whether this is your son
or daughter or wife of father or mother
I just ask can you kindly introduce me
to everyone please simple isn't it yes
we make mistakes we should learn from
those mistakes I raise them correct them
and never repeat them so I'm not sure
that you can completely erase your past
mistakes but I definitely believe that
you can learn from them and try never to
do them again I think the erasing part
comes in two forms one just for yourself
like you erase the mistake you erase
that pattern in yourself so that you
never do it again and in terms of other
people that it might have impacted I
think the best you can do is apologize
you can you know be vulnerable and say
hey I made a mistake here and then at
that point it's up to them if they're
gonna forgive you or not after you've
done everything that you can to try to
make it right I think mistakes are gonna
happen all the time I think mistakes are
part of growth I think if you want to be
a successful entrepreneur you study the
people who you love and look up to
they're the ones who make the most
mistakes the more you make mistakes the
more you're going to eventually win I've
made so many mistakes in my youtube
channel some of them more egregious and
others I think my biggest one was
probably I did a top ten video on Kid
Cudi and I called him kid cootie and I
said that his debut single was night and
day instead of day and night in 2009 his
debut single night and day reached the
top 5 on the Billboard charts his kid
cootie and here his top ten rules for
success and I just got roasted I got
roasted by his superfans in the comments
and listen I deserve it I messed up I
said his name wrong I messed up the name
of his first song and and it feels bad
man it feels really bad but I made a
process to try and make it better for
future ones and I still make some
mistakes every now and then in
mispronouncing somebody's name even
though I've tried to really refine that
down but net-net I think I'm doing a
much better job than I used to and it's
because I made that crazy mistake with
Kid Cudi that I will never forget how to
say his name because of that one mistake
that I made and so I think you'll see
this path for everybody anybody you look
up to any of the success stories that
you call your heroes whether they're our
spiritual leader an entrepreneur an
academic whoever it is that you look up
to examine their success they made
mistake after mistake after mistake
after mistake and then they learned from
it and they said this is not final just
because you made a mistake doesn't mean
that you won't eventually succeed which
is where most people fall down
they make a mistake and then they say
well I can never do this and they never
try again that's the biggest mistake of
all never getting back on the horse and
trying again and so I would strongly
recommend you to you if you are on that
path if you've made a mistake and now
you're having a hard time believing in
yourself to look at the stories of your
heroes and see how many times they
failed especially in the early days of
trying to launch whatever it was that
they were trying to launch nobody is an
instant overnight success there's a lot
of feeling along that path and at least
for me studying those success stories
the early days the 0 to 1 million path
gave me the motivation and drive to say
these people failed so many times that
if I fail I still have a chance and if I
increase the amount of times that I'm
failing micro failures not massive you
know take out a huge mortgage on the
house kind of failures lots of small
failures and you learn from them and
pour it into yourself to get better
every single time if you do that I
guarantee you you'll be successful now
that's the special bonus clips for you
but before that it's the commitment of
the day you watch this video don't just
watch another video and not take action
I want to know what are you committing
to do in your life or in your business
as a result of watching this video leave
it down the count's below I'm really
curious to find out thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much loved
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clips
so many people come up to me and say
Gary it's so hard I look at their
Instagram and they're not posting any of
their content with hashtags which is a
by accident way to pick up exposure in a
world where they have no money when you
have no money when I took over my dad's
business it did three million dollars a
year ten percent gross profit three
hundred thousand dollars before expenses
my first year marketing budget was
fourteen thousand dollars when you have
no money and I built that business from
a three to a sixty million dollar
business in five years I had to make
every penny perfect so I was right about
email marketing in ninety six and I was
right and because of that I had 91% open
rates when Google AdWords came out the
day it came out I paid five cents a
click for words before anybody bid me up
and I was super right and that worked if
it does that lock versus preparation and
do you ever get anything wrong what do
you do I can make them as high I get
everything wrong it's just that I can't
recall it because once it's wrong I'm
moving on to the next thing
like dwell dwelling on what you've
dumped on is the quickest way for the
next thing not to work right yeah so
like so I think I do everything I mean
you know this this is a fun thing to say
some people in the back know this I was
a breakout YouTube star in the first
year 2006 I decided that the right
strategy was to leave YouTube completely
and go to viddler because viddler
offered me equity in their company and
I've left an enormous amount of
attention I deviated from my intention
thesis to do short-term economics and
equity in a company and I lost I lost
Wendy Brock finally came in my life two
years ago we started to try to build up
my YouTube for the first time I was
sitting on 40,000 user followers in a
world where I could have had millions if
I just stayed the course so I make
mistakes all the time
I'm reorganize its based on a mistake I
made the prior year I just don't give a
[ __ ] about my mistakes everybody else
cares about your mistakes if you're
worried about your own mistakes you've
already lost so many hours of TV that
you're putting out is there ever a
moment way of thought I regret that
because you're not sort of carefully
thinking through sort of exactly how
you're coming across on TV I do I regret
it I think there's always sort of
regrets what I never do is sit there and
ponder as if we've made a mistake what I
want to do is find a solution and I call
as I see it and
sometimes that's incorrect and but then
today that's what you're going to get
because I don't I don't sit there and
pretend so do I sit there and waste time
No life's too short the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be
collect a little beacon pay believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details